ハード iv は珍來料理人の
none
me
フレッシュ
はじめちゃんあうーん虫外れの味でそろそろ本格的に実戦4しようと思いますという
意味で今回は
お料理コーナー3私外れ雪お料理が基本的に何もできないんですけどもまぁちょっと
今後の健康面を考えたりしてもうやっぱ料理を素敵に行かなきゃいけないって誰か料理
のアニメなんですけどそれを見てからすげー料理者になったわけなんで今日は大友の
料理していこうと絶とりあえずまずはぜひそうなことからやっていこうと思いますでは
行こう
今度は何を作ろうかと言いますとまぁこちらの猫
どちらも山は山方参考にして作っていきたいと思います今回は縦画臼杵駅ライスを作っ
ていこうと思います材料はこちら
まだ至らなかったで買えました月でやってからね今後は9 the
すまないだ
直截じゃなく牛肉や玉ネギ卵とご飯はまあん許してください
あっはてっつんで自転て泣いちゃうってちょっとて強いです
この前の王双つ一戦に検証コラボ絵できる青協平滑
入線しますネギ後は色々調味料です
この上にさあ清めの塩あるのもそれです早速この舞台を使って作っていきましょう
まずは卵を切るために絡んだまずは温泉玉を作んなきゃいけないのでたまごポケットに
打ち込みます
卵2つファイアーします
持った
あ音ズレた方になるかって待ちます次が玉ねぎれちゃった場合映っていますポーツを今
まで言えなかったんですけど買いましたよ頃
はっはっは子でしょ猫の自然だよ
ハイカム区4位
完成しましたたまでに賛成しました周木切っていきますまず半分いーあー
ok タマネギ切れましたトレパン使ってるよフライパンの上で何か良い色します
だから油とかごはんああごま油入れていきますきて議論できます
ああああああ
ご愛顧祝いやばいやばいもう始まって外せるさあ頬 youtube などでもいる僕
です
はいやってますね解れば雑魚水が減ったんだけどねうん
ほらほら響けじゃないよだーっおばあさん入れます
ん
ブーブー san
で完全ヌード
あああああしねーっに水どっ肉
これをちょっと混ぜていきます
あああああいい香りしてきましたでも1年間匂いが出てきたら次はニックを入れます肉
いきますこういったロッシをする
うためますわ
こうやってジャイロが変わっていたら玉ねぎを入れます
ジャンプする妄想かなはいお肉の色が変わってきたので玉ねぎを入れます様に行くよ
ラストスパートやそれまとめて炒める感じです
いいんじゃないですかさあみんなものすぎだぜ次はこちら引き上げの種を少しだけ入れ
ます
夫
[音楽]
スポピ ok ご覧の守る方は完成でございますしてまずちょっと太郎の様子を見て
みよう
[音楽]
ブーブーどうすりゃいいああ
水をなくせばいいんだ馬頭を出しちゃいましょうこのだけど一歩入っておき
たーーーーーちゃって卵酒ましたぁーっもてねーケトルたままこれで準備完了です
夏はもう簡単ですご飯の上にこの肉を買ってのせてその上に卵ってキロセンター完成
ですじゃあ
じゃあちゃいますかハマーもあっあっはい
ケトルって温度を受け取るだよ真鍋様終わります
[音楽]
ani
始めたんですよ
これでウェイク
はいおっふ
heaven 本当はあるでしょとロッテなるんでしょ
待って撮影になるでしょ
[音楽]
ぬるすぎましたね ok 関西
いやぁまぁ全体的には良かったんですけどもやはり卵ですね
うーん
茹でてしまいましたね取っちゃって予定だったんですけどもうちょっと綺麗にその
きれいに腕ちゃってまぁそこでも問題なく食べられるのではないかなと思いますね早速
食べてみましょう頂 max ぐらい味だよ味
[音楽]
うまいうまいぞこのすげー
を息をコンビに行かなくていいんだよ語学食べに動いてとっても美味しいんですけども
僕だけ食べてためばわからないと思うんで最後にちょっと試食してもらいましょう
どうもし
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ